woke up balls to fans players they're
very personal they're very emotional
it's a symbol the symbol of the event
let's talk about brazuca the official
match ball of the FIFA 2014 World Cup
it's a veces most tested ball you tested
brazuca with over 600 players in 10
countries with 26 different teams the
ball is six panels one panel shape
that's the first time we've ever done
that when the ball is flying that it has
a very nice consistent notation easy to
spot in the air we do a variety of tests
you want to make sure the ball keeps its
shape that it doesn't throw up water
that the rebound is is consistent over
the course of the game but really one of
the most important ones is is the
subjective player feedback was really
getting players used to the ball how do
they think about it how they feel about
it and the comments that we received
back were very consistent very
predictable very playable the method
that we use to create the ball is
thermal bonding it's something that
we've really perfected it allows the
ball to have a very very low water
uptake so from the first minute to the
90th minute the ball is consistent it
has very good shape as well over the
course of time and it has excellent
playability every player touches it it's
played in every game it doesn't win or
lose